let's first discuss how all of this I'm
like Humpty Dumpty sat on a wall and
Humpty Dumpty had a big fall hey guys
welcome to Abby's kitchen so two things
you probably know about me one I am
super pregnant and two I'm a total
foodie and while I'm getting really
excited to meet this baby and to eat all
my favorite foods again I'm also super
anxious to find out if this baby is
going to be a foodie like me so you
might be thinking that you don't have
any control over this especially before
a baby's born however based on some
recent evidence it looks like we may
have some more influence than we think
so I've obviously been testing out this
theory and I'm really excited to share
with you my top tips for raising a
foodie baby before it's even born first
let's discuss how any of this is
possible so new research has shown that
the foods that mom eats can actually
flavor the amniotic fluid which then is
swallowed by the baby
these early sensory experiences can
shape babies preferences for foods and
all of this happens before baby has even
taken its first bite of solid food this
brings me to my tips so tip number one
limit junk food now I get it it can be
really hard to eat healthy when you feel
like throwing up all day and all you can
keep down is buttered toast however
research has actually shown that people
who consume a diet rich in junk food
have a lot of fat sugar and salt in
there may actually produce babies that
have preferences for these kinds of
foods over healthier alternatives I
totally get that sometimes junk food is
all you want to eat but try to make
healthier swaps in you can you're eating
out to help promote a healthy
relationship with food for your baby
tip 2 introduce a wide range of flavors
so exposing your baby to a variety of
flavors may actually improve babies
palate and turn them into a professional
gourmand so studies have found that some
really distinct flavors transfer really
well in utero so these are things like
mint garlic vanilla anise and lots of
spices so try whipping out my favorite
high-protein chicken curry to help
improve baby's palate tip 3 eat a
well-balanced diet
eating a diet rich in fruits and
vegetables may be one of the best ways
to influence your baby's food
preferences and potentially even prevent
picky eating so they tested this theory
by giving some pregnant women carrot
juice and other pregnant women just
water and they found that the babies who
are exposed to carrot juice in their
amniotic fluid were way more accepting
of having carrots in their cereal than
those who are given just water tip 4 try
eating more bitter vegetables generally
children do like salty or sweet foods a
lot more than bitter ones however
exposing them in utero to sand these
flavors may help shape their palate
later on so try incorporating lots of
dark leafy vegetables into your prenatal
diet my channel is filled with lots of
great recipes to help get you started
and tip 5 do not stress if you're
feeling my crap and you can only stomach
soda crackers and cheese puffs do not
worry
honestly the research is not strong
enough to warrant any kind of mom guilt
your baby's palate does not stop warming
at birth and it's way more likely you're
gonna be able to form that palate
through social shaping and through
exposure outside of utero so even though
the research is very early and new I was
just really excited to get baby on board
with my foodie lifestyle and honestly
sometimes it did encourage me to choose
salad over fries well guys I hope you
learned something and enjoyed this video
if you did be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below with some of
the foods that your kid loves that
really surprises you subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]